olivier ans qui appelle les français à
la plus grande vigilance dans les jours
et les semaines à venir avec en ligne de
mire la rentrée des classes dans neuf
jours le protocole sanitaire pour les
écoles dévoilé par jean michel blanquer
air dimanche continue d'inquiéter les
syndicats d'enseignants le point avec
katia technique depuis le ministère de
l'éducation nationale à paris ce matin
jean michel blanquer a ouvert le bal des
annonces de rentrer avec les consignes
pour la rentrée scolaire le 2 septembre
douze millions d'élèves retrouveront les
bancs de l'école suivant un protocole de
niveau 2 qui n'est pas le plus
contraignant puisqu'il existe un niveau
3 et un niveau 4 il est basé sur la mise
en place des gestes barrières le port du
masque obligatoire en intérieur la
désinfection des locaux et la mise en
place de tests à grande échelle et bien
sûr sur la vaccination à partir de 12
ans mais le pass and i ter ne sera pas
exigée pour les personnels et les
enseignants ces mesures ont été
critiquées par de nombreux médecins car
jugée insuffisante les adolescents entre
12 et 17 ans sont en effet la tranche
d'âge la moins vacciner plus de 43% des
12-17 ans n'ont reçu en effet aucune
dose le ministre a donc averti de la
possibilité de se faire vacciner
directement dans les établissements
scolaires pour accélérer les choses dans
le protocole de rentrée il existe de
nombreux moments au contexte sans port
du masque il n'est pas obligatoire pour
les enfants en maternelle ni à la
cantine il y aura toujours des sports en
intérieur et selon les prévisions de
l'institut pasteur c'est chez les
enfants qu'auront lieu la moitié des
nouvelles infections en france le taux
d'incidence est d'ailleurs très élevé en
ce qui les concerne il faut savoir
également que depuis l'apparition du
vaillant delta il y a eu une hausse à
des hospitalisations chez les enfants
avec l'apparition de quelques cas graves
jeudi dernier des médecins ont donc
publié une tribune demandant que le
protocole soient renforcés en niveau 3
au niveau 4 avec par exemple des repas
pris dans les classes des courants
distant ciel l'arrêt du sport en
intérieur il faudrait également purifier
l'air dans les lieux confinés en tout
cas d'ores et déjà les médecins alertent
sur la faiblesse du dispositif